hello dr. Berg here in this video we're
gonna talk about keto and dairy okay can
you do dairy on a keto now in this video
I'm not going to talk about lactose
intolerant or allergies to milk or
casein if the protein in milk I'm mainly
gonna talk about should you do dairy on
a ketogenic diet or not first let's talk
about the yogurt okay
fat-free yogurt with fruit so called
fruit healthy which usually it's like
not just fruit it's like the jelly of
the fruit and all the sugar and
sometimes it's not even fruit at all
it's kind of artificial flavoring it's
47 grams of sugar that's like drinking a
soda that's a lot of sugar fat-free
plain is 19 grams of sugar
that's incredible fat-free Greek is 9
grams so it's a little bit better but
it's still too high and this is per 8
ounces okay eight ounces so it's a cup
whole milk plain is 11 grams of sugar
that's still too high but look at
fat-free plain versus whole milk plain
apparently the fat-free is higher in in
sugars see I'm not even looking at the
carbohydrates I'm looking just in sugar
so yeah so that's interesting so whole
milk plain is better than fat-free plain
fat-free vanilla is 34 grams of sugar
way too high boats milk kefir is 7 grams
so if you were forced to consume some
type of yogurt or kefir obviously this
would be the best this is the second
best okay if you were at gunpoint and
you had eaten right okay look at this
blueberry kefir 20 grams Wow low fat
plain kefir still has 12 grams of sugar
low fat plain key for 11 grams of sugar
this is lactose free and I don't
understand why it's high in sugar
but because lactose is the sugar so I
don't I don't understand that but it's
still it's way too high so that's yogurt
so do you want to do yogurt
Kito the answer is no I'm sorry okay now
let's get to milk 2% milk is 12 grams of
sugar per cup
okay cup is not that big that's too high
half-and-half for your coffee 0.36 grams
so it's less than a gram and Hulk whole
cream like whipping cream is 0.1 so if
you were to use cream in your coffee
though with the whole milk but still
happen happens not that bad okay so can
you do these yes I would get organic and
try to get grass-fed if possible and
this one is a No now what if you do it
just a little bit of milk okay that's
fine but not a lot of milk okay it's
just gonna blow you out of ketosis let's
talk about cheese now when you have
cheese you have this fermentation
product that you have these bacteria
that are eating up the milk sugar and a
lot of that lactose is being lost with
the the way the protein part as it's
coming out of Chiefs in the making of
cheese as well but check this out cream
cheese is less than one one gram it's
point four five grams per cup that's
pretty good so cream cheese is totally
fine pepper jack is zero grams of sugar
awesome cheddar it's zero grams in fact
the more aged of cheeses the better the
less sugar it has mozzarella one point
four grams of sugar per cup still not
bad has a little bit more but look at
this processed cheese processed cheese
you know those little individual wrapped
cheese that most people consume probably
Velveeta and the other processed cheese
that you would buy that everyone's
eating and lunch and the whole thing 19
grams of sugar 19 grams of sugar for
processed cheese that is like way over
the top cottage cheese is six grams Wow
that's it that's a good amount of sugar
so is this a yes or no these are a yes
these are probably a no all right small
amounts but this one's definitely a big
fat no okay now you might be allergic to
cheese because the casein the allergy
that's a separate deal you might be
lactose intolerant that's a separate
deal but when you get consume cheese
grass-fed organic would be the ideal
scene okay thanks for watching hi guys
hey listen I created a pretty amazing
evaluation quiz down below that actually
analyzes your symptoms to find the cause
the root cause of all of your symptoms
the most likely cause so take the quiz
now and we'll send you a report